technology is shrinking smaller phones
smaller laptops smaller everything but
shrinking lenses like those found in
cameras and microscopes has been a
problem material scientists are trying
to replace glass lenses with something
lighter and smaller based on meta
surfaces or engineered materials in this
meta surface lens tiny towers of
titanium dioxide are arranged in a
specific pattern to focus light
different patterns focus different
colors of light in the traditional
microscope lens the glass varies in
thickness between the middle and edges
inside the lens the wavefront of light
is shaped via different thicknesses of
glass this focuses the light at one
specific point beyond the lens in the
meta surface lens the transparent blocks
also bend the light toward the focal
point matching what happens in the glass
lens but with much less material the
tiny meta surface lens building blocks
about 600 nanometers in length can
achieve the same resolution and
magnification as a lens that is 5 to 6
centimeters in length fabrication of
these metal lenses should also be much
more cost effective compatible with
silicon chip technology versus complex
polishing and sometimes stringent
requirements for high-performance lenses
the next step is to focus all of the
visible spectrum into the same focal
length using a meta service lens once
this happens these glitter sized lenses
can replace the lens in a smartphone
regular camera microscope anywhere a
lens might be needed and the great
shrinking and continued